quiero agradecerle al pueblo
estadounidense por su gran apoyo
millones y millones de personas votaron
por nosotros esta noche
y un grupo
de personas muy tristes estás tratando
quedarse con elecciones no vamos a
permitir que eso pase
quiero agradecer a mi familia en la
primera dama vicepresidente pensé que la
señora pensó estar con nosotros
[Aplausos]
y creo que estamos listos para una gran
celebración
estábamos ganando todo y de repente
dejar de contar los resultados han sido
fenomenales y estábamos ya listos para
salir y simplemente celebrar algo que
era tan hermoso tan bueno
es tremendo voto tremendo éxito las
personas de este país han salido en
cifras récords nunca ha habido nada así
para apoyar nuestro movimiento increíble
ganamos estados que ni siquiera
esperábamos ganar como florida logran
los de florida queremos por muchísimo
[Aplausos]
el gran estado de ohio
éramos texas
queremos textos
ni siquiera hemos ganado
[Aplausos]
el 7 por ciento claramente
también en arizona tenemos mucha vida en
esa carrera en declaró que algunas
victorias y es una posibilidad pero hay
muchos votos allá afuera que podríamos
sostener porque ahora estamos entrando a
lo que llaman el territorio de chiapas
eran personas personas que
veo eso esta noche pensamos que es poco
posible que pueda ganar poco probable y
ni siquiera lo necesitamos no
necesitamos eso es un estado que si
hubiésemos ganado hubiese sido puro pero
existe una posibilidad incluso una buena
posibilidad de hecho desde que vi es
originalmente ha cambiado si las cifras
se han reducido bastante
puñados entonces vamos a mantenernos ahí
pero principalmente estamos ganando
pensilvania
[Aplausos]
y estamos por encima por 690 mil volts
no se puede ser que sea cerrado
con 64 por ciento de votos va a ser
prácticamente imposible que nos alcancen
y estamos entrando a las áreas de
pensilvania donde les gusta este
presidente
[Aplausos]
entonces posiblemente vamos a expandir
esa victoria estamos ganando me llegan
yo veo las cifras y dije wow
digo wow eso es mucho por cerca de
300.000 votos y mil 65 por ciento de los
votos que han sido contados y estamos
ganando wisconsin y no los necesitamos
todos los necesitamos porque cuando
agregamos a texas que no había sido
agregado hablé con él y era un
gobernador de texas hace poco tiempo
felicitaciones me llamó a felicitarme
por ganar ganamos creo que no han
acabado con las tabulaciones pero no hay
manera y está prácticamente completo y
medio dime qué es lo que está pasando
nunca había visto algo así puedo decirte
algo nadie lo ha visto ganamos por 170
mil votos en michigan entonces cuando
tocamos todos esos tres estados y vemos
todo lo demás
tuvimos una gran gran noche simplemente
veamos todos estos estados que hemos
ganado esta noche y miramos el tipo de
márgenes que tenemos y de repente no es
como que hayamos ganado por 12 votos
y de repente dije que le pasa a la
elección y tenemos todas estas personas
y anunciantes diciendo buenos
porque saben que no podían ganar
entonces dijeron vamos a la corte y yo
dije esto yo lo predije lo dije desde el
momento en que dijeron que iban a mandar
decenas de miles de votos porque vamos a
ganar y si ellos no ganan entonces nos
van a llevar a la costa entonces
florida fue una tremenda victoria 377
mismos textos como dijimos ohio
piensa en esto ohio en un gran estado yo
amo a yo esperamos por 8.1 por ciento
[Aplausos]
casi 500.000 votos
carolina del norte una gran victoria
para caminar al norte
y estamos liderando por 76 mil votos y
prácticamente no queda nada por contar y
de repente todo lo detienen esto es un
fraude para el pueblo estadounidense es
una desgracia para el país estábamos
listos para ganar esta elección
francamente ganamos esta elección
[Aplausos]
entonces nuestro objetivo ahora es
asegurar la integridad por el bien de
esta nación es un gran momento este es
un gran fraude fraude mayor para esta
nación queremos que se utilice la ley de
manera apropiada entonces iremos a la
corte suprema
queremos que tengan los votos no
queremos que encuentren más votos a las
4 de la mañana y los agreguen a las
vistas ese es un momento muy triste para
mí este es un momento muy triste y vamos
a ganar esto y en lo que a mí concierne
ya emocionantes entonces simplemente
quiero agradecerles y quiero agradecer
gracias por el apoyo agradecer a las
personas que han trabajado con nosotros
y señor vicepresidente diga unas cuantas
palabras por favor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
quiero también agradecer a más de 60
millones de estas evidencias que ya han
votado por cuatro años más de donación
[Aplausos]
y los votos siguen siendo contados y
vamos a mantenernos vigilantes como dijo
el presidente el derecho al voto ha sido
el centro de nuestra democracia desde la
fundación de este país y vamos a
proteger la integridad del voto y
realmente creo con todo mi corazón con
las márgenes extraordinarias que usted
ha inspirado señor presidente de los
estados que acaba de escribir y la
manera como usted lanzó este movimiento
en el país para hacer eeuu grande de
nuevo realmente creo como lo hace usted
también que estamos en el camino a la
victoria y haremos a eeuu grandes de
nuevo de nuevo
gracias en el presidente
gracias a todos
[Música]